stuttgart ein mob von 5 100 randalierern
plündert geschäfte verletzt 19
polizisten
es gibt 24 festnahmen politik und
experten sind sich einig solche szenen
hat es noch nie gegeben
die polizei spricht von frust in der
event- und partyszene
viele sehen das anders nicht nur weil
hier in stuttgart müssen uns damit
beschäftigen wie es passieren kann dass
jugendliche insbesondere auch mit
migrationshintergrund zum teil uns in
gleiten womit haben wir es zu tun
drohen solche gewaltausbrüche auch
anderswo in stuttgart vor allem sehr
berührt und der schande dass ich gebe
euch vollkommen ein rechtes offenbar vor
die polizei in vielen und zwar überall
nicht mehr als unser freund und helfer
also es gibt länder die würden sich
freuen wenn sie solche beamten hätten
wie wir die uns helfen also offenbar
brücke dieses bild das halte ich für
ganz gefährlich und eine weitere
entwicklung gesehen habe halte ich für
gefährlich es wurde er aus einer
einfachen drogenkontrolle er es wurde
ein drogendelikt kontrolliert und daraus
hat sich etwas formiert was irgendwann
mehrere hundert menschen in ihrer
aggression packte und ich glaube dass
das eine ganz gefährliche entwicklung
ist also offenbar braucht es manchmal
gar keine formulierung eines ziels oder
einer meinung sondern es braucht
offenbar die pure aggression dass man es
schafft des menschen die lemminge
hinterherlaufen und etwas folgen von dem
sie eigentlich inhaltlich gar nicht
wissen worum es geht und ich glaube das
ist ein riesen gefahr und da müssen wir
eben ganz genau hinhören woher kommt
dieser frust im wm betrifft ist da ist
natürlich bei spielt es auch eine rolle
ist ein migrationshintergrund oder nicht
denn offenbar vielleicht haben ja auch
manchmal fehler gemacht in der integre
und integrationsarbeit vielleicht machen
wir fehler bei unseren jugendlichen die
politik gefragt woher kommt diese
aggression und da müssen wir die frage
in alle richtungen
[Musik]